des policiers cagoulés et habillés en
civils assiège à Pétionville la
résidence officielle du Premier ministre
par intérim d'Haïti il cherche Ariel
henriale
on va attaquer tous les ministres tous
les directeurs généraux il faut une
révolution un bain de sang on veut que
justice soit rendue à nos frères tués
leur colère a culminé après que 6 de
leur confrères ont été abattus hier et
leur corps nu exhiber dans la rue une
autre provocation des gangs de rue qui
avait tué d'autres policiers la semaine
passée
un mouvement de protestation et de
colère au sein même de la police qui
trouve dès qu'elle n'avait pas assez de
de support du commandement surtout que
dans les deux cas les policiers avaient
demandé du renfort et ne l'avait pas
obtenu et ont été ainsi massacrés
[Musique]
mais c'est à l'aéroport que le premier
ministre se trouvait alors ils sont
allés l'accueillir des échauffés ont
éclaté entre la garde rapprochée d'Ariel
Henry et les policiers
des coups de feu retentissent la
situation à chaotique selon des médias
locaux le Premier ministre s'est réfugié
dans les quartiers généraux de la police
aéroportuaire avant d'être extrait vers
une destination inconnue cruel c'est que
le premier ministre lui-même avait été
à la réunion du Ceylac précisément pour
aller demander la pluie des pays
latino-américains vis-à-vis de la
question sécuritaire donc
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
reviennent et qui puisse même pas se
rendre chez lui les policiers frondeurs
accusent les politiciens de connivence
avec les groupes criminels je pense
qu'il y a des
preuve selon lesquelles certains
éléments dans l'actuel gouvernement ou
dans le parti au gouvernement le phtk
ont maintenu des relations étroites avec
certains chefs
idem pour des sénateurs et des députés
de l'opposition
Haïti vit une crise sur plusieurs fronts
sur le plan politique c'est le vide
institutionnel et l'actuel gouvernement
gouverne par décret et n'a pas été élu
il y a pas un élu dans le pays sauf
peut-être au niveau municipal mais au
niveau national ni le Premier ministre
ni son cabinet il y a pas de Sénat il y
a pas de chambre de députés donc ça
c'est un ça c'est un volet très
important de de la crise pour cette
expert réglez le problème de la violence
revient d'abord à relancer le processus
électoral et à y inclure toutes les
composantes politiques et de la société
civile on entend beaucoup parler d'une
solution haïtienne c'est principe
important c'est sérieux parce que les
solutions venant de l'extérieur n'ont
pas été non pas rencontrer les résultats
produits les résultats escomptés dans le
passé
et les interventions internationales
sont impopulaires en Haïti sans un
gouvernement élu des pays comme le
Canada ou les États-Unis ne peuvent
envisager une intervention malgré les
appels de l'ONU ici Yasmine Hayat
Radio-Canada Montréal